well the leadership debate is uh
certainly heating up we'll lose another
one of them today they want the top
prize that of being prime minister and
that and the pm is uh hosting his final
cabinet meeting today
it's one year today since freedom day uh
last year when we were able fully to
reopen our economy and our society that
was ahead of other comparable countries
why were we able uh to do it it was
because we had the fastest vaccine
rollout uh in uh of any major economy
and uh
i'm proud of what we did some of course
i remember at the time said that opening
up in that way opening up retail opening
up hospitality opening up our country in
the way that we did they said it was
reckless uh they said it was uh going to
be a threat to the world i remember
somebody uh saying and look i've got to
be honest it wasn't an easy decision
we should never forget the suffering
caused by that pandemic and we grieve
for the
families of the many thousands of people
whose lives were cut short
but i have to say i do think it was the
right decision
and because we were able to go ahead in
that way and to open up we were able to
achieve the fastest economic growth last
year of the g7 today we have
unemployment at or near uh record lows
or the lowest uh since uh 50 years
we're in the middle of a heat wave prime
minister
we want to know about that absolutely as
well
maybe he will go on to talk about that
but we must leave it there for now
sitting next to the chancellor there of
course he's got his mansion house speech